the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu alright so yesterday in the
recitation we talked a little bit about
how to debug programs on cell today I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
sort of debugging peril programs in
general and give you some common tips
that might be helpful in sort of helping
you track down problems that you that
you run into and as you might have sort
of gotten a feel for yesterday debugging
parallel programs is harder than sort of
normal sequential programs so in normal
sequential programs you have your
traditional set of bugs which parallel
programs inherit so that doesn't get
much harder but then you add on new
things that can go wrong because of
parallelization so things like
synchronization things like deadlocks
things like data races so you have to
get those right and now you have to
debug your program and figure out how to
do that and one of the things you'll see
here is a lot of tools might not be as
good as you'd like them to in terms of
providing you to functionality for
debugging and add to that that parallel
bug bugs and parallel programs often
just go away if you change you know one
instruction in your or one statement in
your code your reorder things and all of
a sudden the bug is gone it's kind of
like those pointer problems and see
where you might add word add new
variable somewhere and problems gone or
you add a printf and the problem is gone
so here it gets harder because those
things can sort of get rid of deadlocks
so it makes it really hard to repeat
have an experiment that you can repeat
and come down to where the problem is so
what might you want in a debugger so
this is a list that I've come up with
and maybe if you have some ideas you
will want to throw them out but I'm
thinking in terms of G bugging parallel
program what I want is a visual
debugging system that really lets me see
all the processors that I have in my
network in my
to process our system and that includes
the actual computing and the actual
network that's their inter connecting
all the processors are going to be
communicating with each other so I'd
like to be able to see what code is
running on each processor I'd like to
see which edges are being used to sort
of send messages around might want to
know which processors are blocked that
might help me identify deadlock problems
and for these kinds of scenarios it
might be tricky to sort of define step
because there's no global clock you
can't sort of force everybody to proceed
through one step what's one step on one
processor might be different on another
especially if they're not all running
the same code so how do you actually do
that without a lack of without a global
clock so that can get a little bit
tricky and it likely won't help with
data races because I'm sort of looking
at global communication problems i'm
looking at trying to identify what's
deadlock and what's not so if there are
data races this kind of tool may or may
not help with that I've been in general
this is sort of the tool that I would
build for debugging and I looked around
on the web to see what's out there for
debugging parallel programs and i found
this called total view this is actually
something you have to buy it's not free
i don't know if they have evaluation
licenses or licenses for academic
purposes it kind of gets close to some
of the things i was talking about you
have processors it shows you
communication between those processors
how much data is being sent through this
particular version uses MPI which we
talked about in previous lectures so
it's sort of helpful and being able to
see the computation looking at the
communication and tracking Mountain bugs
but it doesn't get much better from
there you know how many people have used
print us for debugging it's probably the
right it's the most popular way of
debugging in even I still use it for
debugging some of the cell programs
we've been writing and I know the TAS
actually use this as well and yes a you
got first hands-on experience with gdb
and energy DB is nice debugger but it
lacks a lot of things that you might
want specialty for debugging parallel
programs and you know you saw for
example that you have multiple threads
you need to be able to switch between
the threads getting the context right
being able to name the variables
is tricky so there's a lot of things
that could be sort of improved and there
are some research debuggers like
something we've built as part of the
streamit project stream a debugger I'll
show you some screenshots just so you
can see what we can do so in the stream
at debugger remember we have so this is
actually built in Eclipse and you can
download this off the web as well and
you can look at your stream graph
unfortunately I couldn't get a split
joint in there much to Bill's dismay so
you can't see for example the split join
all the communication but each one of
these is a filter filter and if you
recall the filter is a computational
element in your stream graph and
interconnected by channels so channels
communicate data and so what you see
here we might not be able to quite see
actually see the data it's being passed
through from one filter to the other and
you can actually go in there and change
the value if you wanted to or highlight
particular value and see how it flows
down through the graph if you had a
split joint then you might be able to in
fact you can't do this you can look at
each path of the split joint
independently and you can look at it in
sequence and because the split join has
nice semantics it's actually you can
replicate the behavior because of all
the static nature's everything is
deterministic so this is very helpful we
did a user study two years ago almost
with something like 30 MIT students who
use a see bugger and gave us feedback on
it and you know one of the things so we
gave them like 10 problems 10 code those
10 code snippets each of them had a bug
in we asked them to find it and so
there's a lot of them found the debugger
to be helpful and being able to track
the flow of data and being able to see
what goes wrong so if you had for
example division that resulted in men
and not a number of floating-point
division you can immediately see it on
the screen so you know exactly where to
go look for it you know doing that with
printf with printf smite not be as easy
so sometimes visual debugging can be
very nice unfortunately visual debugging
for the cell isn't that great so this is
the cell plug-in in Eclipse I've
mentioned this to some of you if you
want to run it you can run it from
PlayStation 3 but if you run if more
than one of you is running it then you
that it becomes unusable because of
memories memory issues you can install
this on other Linux machines and have
remotely debug on the playstation 3
hardware so they can sort of the two
remote machines can talk through GV
ports I can talk to you about how to set
that up if you want to but it doesn't
really add anything over Emacs for
example is just might look fancier than
Emacs window or gdb on the command line
prompt so this is the code from
yesterday these are the exercises we
asked you to do you can look at the
different threads if you've debug Java
programs in Eclipse they should look
very familiar you can look at the
different variables you still have the
naming problem so yes I remember you
have to qualify which can control block
you are looking at it's still the same
kind of issue you have to do some
trickery to find it here and it doesn't
have sort of the nice visual aspect of
showing you which code is running on
which SPE and you might not be able to
sort of find mailbox synchronization
problems it may be those things will
come in the future and the fact they
they likely will but a lot of that is
sort of still lacking so what do you do
in the meantime you know in the next two
weeks as you're writing your programs so
I've looked around for you know some
tips or some talks and lectures and what
people have done in terms of improving
the process for debugging parallel codes
and probably the best thing I found is
this thing it is talk that was given at
University of Maryland defect patterns
and so I it was just the rest of these
slides are sort of largely drawn from
that talk I'm going to identify just a
few of them and sort of give you some
examples so you can understand what to
look for and what are some common
symptoms what are some common prevention
techniques so the defect defect patterns
just like the programming patterns we
talked about sort of meant to help you
sort of conjure up to right contextual
information you had you know what are
things you should look for if you're
communicated with somebody else what
kind of terminology do you use for that
you don't have to explain things down to
every last detail and at the end of this
course one thing I'd like to do is maybe
get some feedback from each of you as to
what are some of the problems that you
ran into in writing your programs and
how you actually want about and
debugging them and maybe we can come up
with a cell defect patterns
and maybe sell defect recipe recipes for
resolving those defect patterns so
probably the worst one of all and the
easiest one to fix is that you have new
language features or new language
extensions that are not well understood
and this is especially true when you
take a you know class of students and
they don't really know the language
there are no all tools and you ask them
to do you know a project in four weeks
and you expect things to work so there's
a lot for for everybody to sort of pick
up and understand so you might have
inconsistent types that you use in terms
of calling function there might be
alignment issues which some of you have
run into you might use wrong functions
you know you know it functionality you
want you just don't know how to name it
and so you might use the wrong function
some of these are easy to fix because
you might get a runtime a compile-time
error so if you have mismatch in
function parameters and you can fix that
very easily some defects you know very
natural to parallel programs might not
come up until runtime so you might end
up with crashes or just erroneous
behavior and I really think it's
probably easiest one to fix and the
prevention technique that that would
recommend is you know if there's
something unfamiliar about or you're not
sure about how to use something ask but
also you don't need to know all the
functions that are available in and sort
of and something like the cell language
extensions for see yes there are a lot
of functions you nerd manuals hundreds
of pages and you can't possibly go
through it all and nobody becomes an
expert in everything but understand just
a few basic concepts and features so
we've you know David identified a bunch
that he's found useful for writing and
the programs and some of the ones that
are up on on the web page on the recipes
for for this course list a few more and
so this might help you in sort of just
understanding how these functions work
understanding basic mechanisms that they
give you and that's good enough because
it will help you get by and certainly
for sort of doing the project under
short time constraints you don't need to
know all the advanced features that cell
might have or you can probably just pick
them up on the fly as you need them
okay so what are some more interesting
problems that come up I think it one
that is probably not too unfamiliar is
this pasty composition problems so if
you remember space decomposition is
really data distribution you have a
serial program that you want to paralyze
and what that means is you have to
actually send data around to different
processors so that each one knows how to
compute locally and here you might get
things like segmentation faults
alignment problems you might have index
out of range errors and what this comes
of is sort of forgetting to change
things or overlooking some simple things
that don't carry over from the
sequential case to the parallel case so
what you might want to do is sort of
validate your distributions and your
memory partitions correctly so what's an
example so suppose you had sort of an
array or a list of cells each cell has a
number and what you want to do is for
each step of the computation for any
given cell you want to add the value to
the left of it and the value to the
right of it so here we have cell 0 has
the value to we'll assume that the end
is connected to refer so this is like a
circular list a circular buffer so
adding the left and right neighbor would
get me in this case 3 plus 1 4 and so on
and so forth so and you want to repeat
this computation for n steps this might
be very common in any computations where
you're doing your neighbor communication
so what's a straightforward sequential
implementation well you can use two
buffers right one for the current time
step and you do all the calculations in
that and then you swat you sort of use
the next another buffer for the next
time step and then you swap the two and
so the code might look something like
this a sequential C code you know my two
buffers here's my loop I get right into
one buffer and then I switch the two
buffers around any questions so far okay
so now what are some things that can go
wrong when you try to paralyze this
so how would you actually paralyzed this
could well we saw in some of your labs
for example that you can take a big
array split up in smaller chunks and
assign each chunk to one particular
processor so we can use that technique
here so each processor you know we have
n of them or rather size of them and
it's going to get some number of
elements and so each time step we have
to compute locally all the
communications but then there's some
special cases that we need to treat at
the boundaries right so if i have this
chunk and i need to do in my near
neighbor communication i don't have this
particular cell so i have to go out
there and request it and similarly
somebody has to send me this particular
data item so there's some data exchange
that has to that has to happen so in the
decomposition you know you write your
parallel code here each buffer is a
different size and what you do is you
have some local which says this is how
much of the data i'm getting so n is
total number of elements size the number
of processors so and local essentially
tells me the size of my chunk and I'm
iterating through from 0 to n local and
I'm doing essentially the same
computation so what's a bug in here
anybody see it sort of giving some hints
as things highlighted in red or there's
something wrong with the things
highlighted in red
and it's another hint so this is
essentially the computations going on
every processor this is my buffer and at
every step i have to do two calculations
taking care of the boundary edges and
you ready wants to take a stab
next but 40 right so what might be a fix
for that so next buffer 0 so if this is
0 then buffer of X minus 1 plus this
points to what so here's the yeah right
it's exactly two local plus one because
you're going to duty so that's one bug
the other thing is sort of the
assumption that your data elements might
be divisible by the number of processors
that you have so you picked a
decomposition that might not be
symmetric across all processors so it's
a more subtle I think to to keep to keep
in mind of so that's one particular kind
of problem that might come up when
you're decomposing data and replicating
among different processors so you have
to be careful about you know what are
your edge case order your boundary cases
going to be and how are you going to
deal with those more difficult one is
synchronization so synchronization is
when you're sending data from one
processor to the other and you might end
up with deadlock as one is trying to
send the others trying to send and
neither can make progress until the
other is received so your program hangs
you get undetermined istic behaved
non-deterministic behavior or output you
know every time you run your program you
get a different result that can drive
you crazy so some of the defects can be
very subtle you might not you know it's
probably where you'll spend most of your
time trying to figure it out and so one
of the ways to prevent this is to
actually look at how you orchestrating
your communication and doing it very
carefully so look at for example what's
going on here so this is the same
problem and what I'm doing is now this
is the parallel version and I'm sending
sort of the boundary cases the boundary
cells to the different processors and
this is an spm deprogram so an spm d
program is has every processor running
essentially the same code so this code
is replicated over n processors and
everybody's trying to do the same thing
so what's the problem with this book
with this code we're doing ass end of
next buffer 0 and here rank essentially
just says each processor has a rank so
this is a way of identifying things so
I'm trying to send it
to the previous guy I'm trying to send
it to the next guy and here I'm sending
the value at the far extreme of the
buffer to the next processor and it's a
previous processor anybody seen you
what's wrong here yeah imagine they're
blocking sense right so this will
deadlock right so this will deadlock
because this processor is trying to send
here this processor is trying to send
here but neither receiving yet so
neither makes progress so how would you
fix this and as you pointed out you you
might not want to use a blocking send
all the time so if your architecture
allows you to to have different flavors
of communication so synchronous versus
an asynchronous a blocking versus non
blocking you'll want to avoid using
constructs that can lead you to deadlock
if you don't need to and the other
mechanism this was pointed out briefly
in in the talk on parallel programming
you want to order your sends and
receives properly so alternate them so
well you have a send in one processor
receiving the other and you can use that
to sort of prevent deadlock and get the
communication patterns right it could be
more interesting cases that come up if
you're communicating over our network
where you might end up with cyclic
patterns and leading to two loops and
that also can create some problems for
you the last 2 i'll talk about aren't
really bugs in that they might not cause
your program to break or compute
incorrectly things might work properly
but you might not get the actual
performance that you're expecting so
these are sort of performance books or
performance defects so a side effect of
parallelization it's often the case that
you know you're focusing on your
parallel code and you might ignore
things that are going on your sequential
code and that might lead you to
essentially you spent all this time
trying to paralyze your code but your
end result is not getting the
performance that you expect because
things look sequential so what's wrong
here so as an example imagine that we're
doing a set of reading data from
it one processor in the previous case I
didn't show you how we were reading data
into the different buffers but suppose
we were getting it from some files for
input buffer so now we have an S bmd
program again everybody's trying to read
from this buffer what could go wrong
here really have an idea so every
processor is opening the file and then
it's going to figure out how much to
skip and it'll start reading from that
location so everybody's reading from a
file that's okay nobody's modifying it
but what can go wrong here
right right so essentially sequential
eyes your execution because reading from
the file system becomes the bottleneck
so you'll want to schedule input and
output carefully and you might find that
not everybody needs to do the input and
output right only one processor has to
do the input and then it can distribute
it to all the different processors so in
the master-slave model which will you
know a lot of you are using for the sale
programming you know the master can just
read the data from the input file and
distribute it to everybody else so this
avoid some of the problems with input
and output and you can have similar
kinds of problems if you're reading from
other devices it doesn't have to be the
file system so here's another one a
little more subtle so you have you're
generating data hey
no sir here just essentially the master
weeds to file as part of the
initialization right and then you
distribute it so distribution can happen
at runtime so it's the the
initialization you don't care about
because hopefully that's a small part of
code and so in this code only the mat so
this this code is guarded by rank equals
master so only it does this code and
then here you might have a command that
says wait until I've received it and
then execute or in on the cell then
these might be to SB create threads that
you happen after you've read the data so
hopefully initialization time is not
something you're concerned about too
much so if you're generating data on the
fly or dynamically so here we might use
the S Tran function to sort of start
with a random seed and then fill in the
buffer with some random data so what
could go wrong here so an s friend you
know in when you're using a random
function sorry its type of this is the
same function when you're using a random
you know a pseudo-random number
generator you have to give it a seed and
if everybody starts off with the same
seed then you might end up with the same
random number sequence and if that's
something you're using to sort of
paralyze your computation you might in
effect end up with the same kind of
sequence on each processor and you lose
all kinds of parallel paralyzation so
there's some hidden civilization issues
and some of the functions that you might
use that you should be aware of ok and
the last one I'll talk about is
performance scalability defect so here
you paralyze your code things look good
but you're still not getting to put
you've taken care of all your iOS you're
still not getting the performance you
want so why is that you might have
remember you're a Modell's law and what
you want is an efficiency that's linear
every time you add one processor you
want sort of an equal in the equivalent
number you want a straight line curve
between a number of processors and speed
up so should be a linear relationship so
you might see sublinear speed ups and
you'll want to figure out why that is
and some of the common causes here and
this is
we serve the in-depth focus of the next
talk is unbalanced the amount of
computation remember dynamic load
balancing versus static load balancing
your work estimation might be wrong and
so you might end up with some processors
idling other processors doing too much
work and so the way to prevent this is
actually look at the work that's being
done and figure out whether it's
actually roughly the same amount of work
everywhere and here you might need
profiling tools to help and so I'm going
to talk about this a lot more detail in
next in the next lecture so in summary
there are lots of different bugs that
you might come up to come up with
there's sort of a few that I've
identified here some common things you
should look out for so the erroneous use
of language features understand only a
few basic concepts of the entire
language extension set that you have
space decomposition side effects from
paralyzation don't ignore the sequential
code and the last one is trying to
understand your performance scalability
but there are other kinds of bugs like
data races for example so what can you
do with those so remember data races you
have different concurrent threads and
they're trying to update the same memory
location and so depending on who gets to
write first and when you actually do you
read you might get a different result so
with data rates detection this is these
things are actually getting better there
are tools out there that will
essentially generate traces as your
program is running so for each thread
you instrumented and you look at every
load store that executes and then what
you do is you look at the loads and
stores between the different threads and
see if there's any intersections and any
orderings that might give you a sort of
erroneous behavior and so this is
getting better it's getting more
automated until thread checkers one
example there are others and I really
think the trend in debugging will be
towards trace based systems you'll have
things like checkpointing so as your
program is running you can sort of take
a snapshot of where it is in the
execution and you can use that snapshot
later on to sort of inspect it and see
what went wrong I think you might even
have features like replay in fact some
people are working on this in research
and an industry so you might be able to
say something went wrong here's my list
of checkpoints can you replay execution
from this particular stage in the
computation so it helps you sort of
focus down on in the entire lifetime of
execution on particular chunk where
things have gone wrong and this is sort
of a personal dream I think one day
we'll have the equivalent of a tivo for
your programs so and you can use this
for debugging so my program is running
something goes wrong I can rewind it I
can inspect things do my traditional
debugging change things maybe even and
then start sort of replying things india
and letting the program executes and in
fact we're working on things like this
here at MIT and with collaborators
elsewhere so this was sort of a short
lecture you'll take a break you can do
the quizzes a note on the quizzes there
are two different kinds of questions
they're very similar just one word is
different and so you'll want to just
keep that in mind when you're discussing
it with others and then you know about
5-10 minutes and then we'll continue
with the rest of the talks lecture 2
thanks